let's go to rachel hey chris
congratulations what does it mean to you
guys to get back home court in this
series and grab this big win
mean a lot showed a lot of fight showed
a lot of fight man
guys on both sides you know banged up
it's the playoffs that's what it's going
to look like
but we showed a lot of fighting got this
win monty said he thinks your range of
motion in this game was the best it's
been since the injury how do you feel
and what did you have to do the last
couple days to just get onto the sport
it's been a lot it's been a lot going on
met with coach before the game told me
he was going to hit me
told me he was going to sit me tonight i
told him hell nah just give me a couple
minutes
see what i can do god is good you know i
mean i come from a praying family my mom
and my daddy
all day long pray for me and it's just a
game
people got a lot of tougher things going
on but i love to play this game
so just to get out there and be able to
do this with my team it's 2-2
still got a lot of work to do what do
you want to tell especially the younger
guys on your team about the next few
days and getting ready for that pivotal
game five ain't no next few days
it's one day it's one day it's get your
rest
get your recovery game five gonna be a
dog fight we're going back home though
phoenix we gonna need you thanks so much
chris appreciate it